Kollegen von NTV haben heute eine sehr
schöne Umfrage gemacht nämlich einfach
mal die Frage gestellt haben sie
verstanden was die Ampel da beschlossen
hat was glauben Sie wie viel Prozent
haben mit Jahr gestimmt
naja wenn Sie das hier schon anbringen
dann wird der Wert nicht zu hoch gewesen
sein umso schöner dass wir heute darüber
reden können damit der Prozentwert am
Ende noch höher ist als am Anfang was
waren es
15%. 40 40 die verstanden haben worum es
ging was glauben sie vor allem Feld
wie waren wie hat der SPD bei der
letzten Bundestag war abgeschnitten 25
25 7
also ich löse jetzt mal auf und Kevin
kühn das kennt offensichtlich seine
Pappenheimer 13 % sagten ja ich habe es
verstanden und 87% haben einfach nicht
kapiert worum es dagegen wie erklären
Sie sich das so viele Menschen nicht
verstanden haben was sie in dieser fast
schon historischen besprochen haben
gut nun sind koalitionsausschüsse und
auch ihrer Ergebnisse nicht dafür da
dass danach das Papier wie von der
Kanzel vorgelesen wird und alle sagen ah
jetzt habe ich es verstanden sondern da
muss jetzt natürlich auch in den
nächsten Tagen sie haben es gestern
Abend schon in der Sendung gemacht wir
machen heute weiter genau das muss jetzt
hinsichtlich ohne Erfolg oder die
Einschaltquoten müssen höher werden
das muss jetzt natürlich ein Alltags
Deutsch übersetzt werden und da werden
wir heute sicherlich drüber sprechen an
vielen Stellen auch noch konkretisiert
werden dann auch wenn 16 Seiten geworden
sind das ist ja noch keine
ausführungsvorschrift die wir dort
gemacht haben wenn es jetzt um
Heizsystem oder so geht und die Leute
wollen logischerweise am Ende wissen was
heißt das jetzt konkret für mein Leben
was heißt das für meine Heizung im
Keller was heißt das für mein Auto
draußen auf der Einfahrt und so weiter
und so fort und das hat ihnen natürlich
bislang noch keiner im Einzelfall
dargelegt vielleicht kommen wir heute
ein bisschen näher an ja unbedingt
sollten wir mal versuchen ein bisschen
wie erklären Sie sich das
das eigentlich doch kein guter Befund
wenn der plötzlich so viele Leute sagen
ich habe gar nicht verstanden warum es
da ging es geht wie Kevin Kühnert sagt
es geht um ihr Leben und es wird jetzt
ganz konkret und ehrlich gesagt stehen
da auch Zumutungen drin die man den
Leuten noch mal dringend erklären ich
glaube die Politiker der erstmal immer
auch im tunnelproblem da kommen dann
Menschen zusammen die sich die
spiegelstriche ausgedacht haben um ihre
Interessen die sie ihrer Partei
versprochen haben dann auch in ein
Papier unterbringen müssen niemand denkt
ja wirklich wir müssen was aufschreiben
was die Menschen verstehen sorry aber
das ist ja nicht der Anfang sondern
erstmal wir müssen das Durchsetzen wir
müssen das durchsetzen was wir danach in
der Gesetze aber dann auch wirklich
durchbekommen als die Chefs besprochen
haben und so weit wir wissen hat das
Kanzleramt das Papier ja zu 95%
vorbereitet gehabt bevor es überhaupt zu
größeren Koalitionsausschuss gab gab es
einen vorpapier da stand das alles schon
drin sehr viel für die FDP was wiederum
zum Unmut bei den Grünen geführt und
dann kommen die da alle zusammen und
dann beugen die sich da 40 Stunden nur
noch um die spiegelstriche aber das
nicht so aufschreiben dann hätte ich
weniger Probleme mit meiner Partei das
führt nicht zu Verständnis hat 15 von 16
Seiten waren vorher schon fertig das ist
unsere Information ja
man nennt das Vorbereitungen aus dem
Kanzleramt
er Kühnert also ich gehe jetzt nicht in
die Details von solchen Veranstaltungen
rein weil ich finde das gehört ja auch
nicht hin aber natürlich darf man sich
einen Koalition doch hier jetzt gerade
mal hin netter Versuch dafür sind wir ja
da helfen können
sie reden möchten über alles ja Sinn und
Zweck eines Koalitionsausschusses ist
auf jeden Fall nicht dass alle
zusammenkommen und vor einem leeren
Tisch sitzen und dann jemand sagt
worüber wollen wir dann sprechen
natürlich macht man sich vorher Gedanken
was Thema ist und natürlich wird auf der
Arbeitsebene auch schon miteinander
darüber gesprochen was wollt ihr was
wollen wir viele Vorhaben sind ja auch
nicht neu also das Thema Heizung über
das wir heute ja auch sprechen werden
ist den ja nicht Sonntagabend
eingefallen sondern dass es eine Novelle
des Gebäude Energiegesetzes geben soll
steht im koalitionsverkehr da sind Infos
durchgesickert da muss man sich jetzt
nicht überrascht zeigen wenn man Sonntag
abends zusammen kommt sondern natürlich
gibt es dazu Überlegung die auch schon
zu Pap angebracht wurden und das macht
das Arbeiten am Text dann auch gleich
mal ganz kurz was fragen woher ist das
denn durchgesickert diese diese Details
zu diesem Gesetz zu dem Gebäude zur
Heizung wir wissen es nicht und deswegen
ist es eine Vermutung nö und wenn ich
eine hätte würde sie uns trotzdem nicht
weiterhelfen die Grünen sagen sie waren
es nicht ja na ja wer soll sich jetzt
hinstellen und sagen wir sind gewesen es
muss ja auch gar nicht ein politischer
Akteur gewesen sein sowas geht auch
manchmal über Schreibtische von Leuten
die irgendein anderes Interesse haben
das ist aber jetzt echt keine Sensation
die das erste Mal rund um das Gebäude
Energiegesetz passiert ist sondern also
ihre Arbeit besteht zum maßgeblichen
Teilen daraus dass Informationen vom
Laster runterfallen die eigentlich nicht
hätten runterfallen sollen ähm und das
gehört zu sein
das ist keine illegale wahre
Informationen Aufklärung
reingeschlichen das wollte ich damit
überlegen unterstellen sondern dass das
eben seiner liberalen Demokratie so was
passiert und jetzt kann man sich da
mehrere Tage drüber aufregen nicht
aufregende sterben oder man kann halt
sagen so ist es lösen ich frage auch
deine Frau Weinfeld naja ich würde mal
sagen einer hat sich darüber ja so
aufgeregt dass es überhaupt erst richtig
interessant geworden ist ich würde mal
behaupten dass ich vermutlich nicht so
sehr viele Leute für die Frage
interessiert hätten wie ein
Gesetzentwurf in einem wie auch immer
gearteten Stadium aussieht wenn ich
einer Sicht dahin richtig richtig
aufgeregt hätte und das macht dann
natürlich für Journalisten auch noch mal
erst recht viel Spaß haben sie gerade
gesagt dass Robert habe den sterbenden
Schwan gemacht hat das habe ich nicht
gesagt doch nein das habe ich überhaupt
gar nichts hat ja jeder so verstanden
was haben sie dann gesagt ich habe
einfach nur ein Bild benutzt und sie
stellen da jetzt Zusammenhänge her die
überhaupt gar nicht da waren völlig aus
dem Zusammenhang und genau ich verstehe
das Leute die am Gesetzen Arbeiten die
in der Ressort Abstimmung sind also wo
zwei Häuser in dem Fall das Wirtschafts-
und klimaministerium das Bauministerium
versuchen komplexe Materie zu
verarbeiten dass die das nicht so
erquicklich finden wenn plötzlich das
ganze auf die große Bühne gezogen wird
und alles schon Anfang des zu besprechen
während man selber noch gar nicht fertig
war ich teile diese Verärgerung aber
indem man die Verärgerung beschreibt und
in schrillen Farben ausmalt ändert sich
an der Tatsache nichts der Geist ist aus
der Flasche raus der Entwurf kursiert
und nun muss man damit irgendwie umgehen
ich frag mal Michael Bröcker könnte es
sein dass vielleicht sogar die SPD was
damit zu tun hat zumindest ist dass die
Vermutung der Grünen die ist
offensichtlich das führende grüne sagen
dass und einer hat heute zu mir an den
sehr interessanten beispielhaften Satz
für das neue Verhältnis zwischen rot und
Grünen gesagt der lautete Olaf Scholz
und die SPD haben mehr Angst vor den
Grünen als vor dem Klimawandel und
dahinter steckt eine neue sozial
liberale Achse die es im
Koalitionsausschuss spürbar gehabt die
gibt es im Text ich sag mal nur als
Beispiel diesen Absatz der wirklich
fdpur ist den hat es im Kanzler
Wasserstoff ready genau also das ist
sehr viel deswegen freuen sich die
Liberalen ja auch immer wie gesagt ich
bewerte das gerade nicht ich beschreibe
das nur die FDP läuft durch Berlin und
freut sich die Grünen laufen durch
Berlin und ärgern sich und das hat vor
allem natürlich mit dem zu tun der beide
Seiten zusammenbringen muss das ist das
Kanzleramt das ist Olaf Scholz da gibt
es natürlich auch ein strategischen
Wettbewerb im linken Lager der heißt SPD
oder grüne und das Olaf Scholz sich in
mehreren Fällen im letzten Jahr immer
wieder auf die Seite der FDP gestellt
hat ist ersichtlich nachweisbar und das
ist jetzt hier im Koalitionsausschuss
eben auch passiert die Grünen sind
massiv verärgert über das was da
passiert ist und deswegen glaube ich
dass es ein permanentes Misstrauensvotum
jetzt immer wieder bei jedem neu
aufkommenden Thema gibt wir gehen jetzt
in die haushaltsverhandlung das ist ein
Friedensgipfel der nur im Momentaufnahme
ist darf ich trotzdem noch mal konkret
nachfragen also wir haben gerade eben im
Hintergrund gesehen und gestern war uns
zugeschaltet und welches Duell geht's
denn da geht's da Scholz versus habe
oder warum geht's da ja natürlich geht
es darum Scholz rechnet fester mit und
das Umfeld von Olaf Scholz das Robert
Habeck der Kanzlerkandidat der Grünen in
drei Jahren wird auch die Grünen rechnen
übrigens damit weil Annalena Bernburg
ihre Chance hatte dass der nächste
Kanzlerkandidat der Grünen Robert Habeck
heißt und damit ist er der Zentrale
Gegner für Olaf Scholz in einem Lager
dass sich ein wenig zumindest aus sich
selbst beißt und die Grünen liegen in
vielen Umfragen vor der SPD und es gibt
sicherlich auch viele Stimmen in der SPD
sie können das ja alles dementieren die
ein Interesse daran haben dass Robert
habecks Popularitätswerte und die Grünen
als fortschrittmotor dieser Koalition
als Antreiber dass die vielleicht auch
mal ein wenig demütiger ausgestaltet
werden bevor wir gleich den
Generalsekretär der spd-fragen was da
drin ist vor beiden fällt versuche
gerade ihr Gesicht zu lesen ja mich
wundert immer das Olaf Scholz so gut
dabei rauskommt
Papier anschaut dann steht da sehr viel
von der FDP drin steht auch sehr viel
über die Grünen und von den Grünen drin
aber nichts aus der SPD und das ein ein
Kanzler der wie sie sagen in drei Jahren
fürchtet gegen den großen
harbeck-antreten zu müssen dass der
einen 16-seitiges Papier auch noch zu
80% selber vorbereitet wovon dann 40%
wahrscheinlich schon Koalitionsvertrag
starten aber dass dieser Kanzler dann
seine eigene Farbe nicht in dieses
Papier malt das wundert mich total das
finde ich super erstaunlich dass da
jemand der die Regierung führt der
Kanzler ist und der ja in wirklich
großen Worten
Wirtschaftswunder verspricht und ähm
ganz große Leistung große große Verträge
große Neuanfänge dass der eigentlich
sich da nicht als Kindergarten drin aber
so und vielleicht Mediator oder als
Moderator betätigt aber nicht als jemand
der politische Vorstellungen hat und
meine Furcht ist so ein bisschen dass er
sich das bei seiner Kanzlerin vorher
abgeguckt hat und dass er das jetzt
einfach so weitermacht
ja ich bin gespannt
hat keine eigene Ambitionen in diesem
Text zu erkennen gegeben mit
Sozialdemokrat mit dem man spricht heißt
es dann doch wir haben doch Mieterschutz
und wir haben die soziale Abfederung
beim Energie beim Gebäude Energiegesetz
in Wahrheit hat Olaf Scholz eines
erreicht und vielleicht war das ein
einziges Ziel die Koalition besteht
weiter fort nein
man muss einmal ganz ganz fragen
dieser Schulterschluss zwischen Olaf
Scholz und Christian Lindner also dieser
Schulterschutz der erkennbar ist
zwischen der SPD und der FDP was sehr
interessant ist gegen die Grünen wessen
Idee war das ihre sie sind ja
Generalsekretär als Mastermind
spindoktor dahinter
ich finde super dass sie auch schon
schmunzeln weil da muss ich nicht mehr
so viel Schmunzeln darüber einmal der
Reihe nach man darf den Charakter eines
Koalitionsausschusses
nicht verwechseln mit den einer
koalitionsverhandlung es geht in einem
Koalitionsausschuss nicht darum zehn
neue Themen die noch nie besprochen
wurden auf den Tisch zu legen und sich
dazu eine Meinung zu bilden der
Koalitionsausschuss und die tägliche
Arbeit in Regierungen und in den
Fraktionen hat ja schon Zielsetzung
vorgegeben also gucken wir uns an um
welche Themen ist jetzt gegangen ist in
diesen drei Tagen es geht um
Emissionsziele die wir in Deutschland
verfolgen es geht um Ziele der
Klimaneutralität es geht um
Entscheidungen was die gebäudeenergie
angeht also das wir anders umgehen
wollen mit Heizsystem das haben wir
schon im Koalitionsausschuss
Koalitionsvertrag geschrieben da stand
drin es war meine Arbeitsgruppe die ich
von der SPD Seite ausgeleitet habe dass
wir das was jetzt gemacht wird ab 1.1.25
machen wollen von einem Jahr nach Beginn
des russischen Angriffskrieges ist
entschieden worden wir ziehen ein Jahr
vor erster erster 24 jetzt geht es um
die Implementierung wie setzt man sowas
am Ende um ohne dass Leute aus ihren
Häusern verdrängt werden ohne dass es
Lebens unpraktische Lösungen gibt wie
steuert man Förderung aus und so weiter
aber es ging nicht mehr um die
Grundsatzfrage
Sektor und die Heizung in Deutschland
sollen die was zum Klimaschutz beitragen
und so ist das bei all den anderen
Themen auch gewesen und deswegen
widerstehe ich da auch als
Generalsekretär der SPD dem Versuch wenn
das schon zwei Parteien sitzen sie ihr
Autobahn wo die eine gerne alles bauen
will was jemals das Licht der Welt in
einem Bundesverkehrswegeplan erblickt
hat und die anderen wollen nie wieder
ein Meter Straße bauen also die F möchte
das und die Grünen wollen nicht
überspitze jetzt ein bisschen aber ich
glaube beide würden sich nicht ganz so
weit davon distanzieren von dem wie ich
es gerade beschreibe so und jetzt was
soll jetzt der Versuch sein der SPD nur
damit die Runde hier stehenden Applaus
spendet am Ende einer
Alleinstellungsmerkmal zusammen sollen
wir jetzt fordern dass alle Autobahnen
rot angestrichen sind und auf Knopfdruck
die internationale spielen damit dann
irgendwie erkennbar ist dass das eine
SPD Projekt wir wollen das Mobilität
funktioniert wir haben dabei weder eine
Extremposition in die eine noch in die
andere Richtung aber wir wissen dass der
Verkehr
war die Partei des Fortschritts
Optimismus die Partei die immer gesagt
hat wir sind diejenigen die für alles
auch glauben eine technische eine
technologische Lösung finden zu können
und diese Farbe hätte man doch wirklich
gerne gesehen der Klima Kanzler der
Klima Kanzler die bauministerin aber
eben auch die Frage welche Bedeutung hat
denn welche Bedeutung hat Fortschritt in
unserer Klima Diskussion und das hat ja
nichts mit einem neuen Koalitionsvertrag
zu tun sondern eben einfach mit der
Frage wie verstehe ich mich als Partei
wie versteht die SPD sich als als
Kanzlerpartei in einer solchen Situation
und dafür würde ich eben sagen
moderieren ist ein bisschen wenig ja
aber das ist jetzt ihre Interpretation
von außen die respektiere ich natürlich
auch aber
was für die SPD zum Beispiel ganz
wichtig waren diesen Papier ist ein
glasklares Bekenntnis dazu dass unser
Ziel im Bereich der automobilen
Mobilität in Deutschland ist das mit 20
30 15 Millionen E-Autos auf der Straße
haben das ist erstmal nur eine Ansage
aber die ist ja ganz wichtig damit man
weiß worauf man orientiert wir haben
heute nicht mal eine Millionen
zugelassene E-Autos in Deutschland sind
jetzt noch sieben Jahre von dem Ziel
entfernt und die Frage was wir uns beide
Million versus 15 richtig genau sehen 7
Jahren schaffen
tauglichen Hersteller in Deutschland die
die automobile auch vom Preis von der
Preisklasse her für die breiten Teile
der Gesellschaft aufbauen die sind
Volkswagen ab 25 26 mit dem e-polo im
Feld unterwegs und dann sind wir endlich
mal einer Preiskategorie wo das auch für
mittlere Einkommen mal halbwegs
erschwinglich ist so dafür muss man sich
aber politische Ziele setzen übrigens
auch das damit man sich nicht verheddert
in sektorziel Diskussion über den
Verkehrssektor denn natürlich kann ich
sagen der Verkehrssektor reißt alle
Ziele und wird sie bis 2030 auch nicht
erreichen wenn ich unterstelle dass ich
nur acht oder zehn Millionen E-Autos bis
2030 auf der Straße habe bei einem
flottenpark von ich glaube 48,5
Millionen Fahrzeugen die in Deutschland
zugelassen sind also solche Zahlen die
erstmal nur Zahlen sind entscheiden in
der konkreten Umsetzung ganz klar
darüber reden
das machen sie sich jetzt wirklich so
einfach ihr Kanzler war im Wahlkampf
unterwegs mit Plakaten da stand drauf
Klima Kanzler und es war immer klar auch
unter der großen Koalition die Sektor
Ziele sind eminent wichtig damit eben
die ressourchefs die verschiedenen
Ministerien ja für ja quasi zum report
bitten müssen und sagen was hast du
geliefert und wenn du nicht lieferst
kommt das sofort in ein Klimaschutz
Sofortprogramm was ja bis heute immer
noch nicht da ist von der Ampel und
jetzt hat man gesagt alle zwei Jahre
aggregierte Ziele natürlich ist das ein
entlastungsprogramm für Volker Wissing
natürlich ist es dafür auf ihn jetzt ein
bisschen abgemildert wurde das sagt
jeder der dabei war dass das de facto
das Ergebnis dieses Koalitionsausschuss
ist Volker Wissing steht nicht mehr so
im Fokus der arme Kerl mit seinen
verkehrsminderungsziel so also einfach
geht das nun mal nicht auf der Schiene
und mit der Straße und das hat Scholz
zugelassen ich will ja nur sagen ein
anderer grüner hat heute ein schönes
Zitat gemacht sagte wenn der Klima kann
wenn der Scholz noch einmal Klima kannst
da sagt verklag ich ihn sagte ein grüner
das ist die sind so sauer darauf dass er
seine eigenen Ziele gefressen hat da
kann man jetzt sagen
20:35 Uhr
meine auch das hatten wir doch als
Deutschland verabredet und stehen jetzt
plötzlich als die da auf die man sich
nicht mehr verlassen kann doch ich kann
nein
ich kann nur auf den kommunizieren nicht
etwas über dieses Papier zu erzählen was
da gar nicht drin steht wir haben uns
überhaupt nicht von Sektor Zielen
verabschiedet aber wir schauen sie
anders an weil Beispiel Verkehrssektor
wir einfach sehen wir sprachen gerade
über das Beispiel der E-Mobilität das
Investition und auch politisches
Engagement im Bereich der
dekarbonisierung des Verkehrssektors
nicht bedeutet dass das morgen oder
übermorgen sich auswirkt sondern wenn
ich große Automobilhersteller in
Deutschland dabei unterstütze ihre
Flotten in Zukunft zu dekarbonisieren
dann dauert das erstmal viele Jahre
Entwicklung und Skalierung und so weiter
und irgendwann kommen sie auf den Markt
und dann passiert was wenn ich mir aber
die sektorziele im Verkehrsbereich
angucke dann hat Volker Wissing oder
jeder andere Verkehrsminister egal wie
er heißt dort jetzt in den nächsten
Jahren ich glaube bis 27 sind es immer
fünf oder sechs Millionen Tonnen CO2 die
eingespart werden müssen das ist eine
Linie die ganz Linie ja runterläuft aber
so entwickelt sich so ein Sektor nicht
im Gebäudebereich ist es genauso genauso
der Großteil ist erstmal da und selbst
wenn man richtig viel bauen und richtig
viel Fahrzeuge verkaufen steht nach 12
Monaten nicht so viel Neues in der
Gegend rum okay dass das grundlegendes
an diesem Sektor ändert deswegen
verabschieden wir uns nicht von den
Sektor Zielen aber wir müssen sie über
schwierig und mittelfristiger betrachten
und zum Beispiel so Landepunkte wie 2030
wo wir dann sagen 15 Millionen darauf
darum geht es die müssen wir in den
Blick nehmen und darüber hinaus muss
wissen aber auch mehr machen also die
Argumentation dass die großen Früchte
noch nicht geerntet werden können darf
natürlich nicht dazu führen dass die
kleinen Früchte nicht mitgenommen werden
das darf keine Ausrede sein keine Frage
ist eigentlich ein schöner Trick Frau
Weidenfeld wenn man weiß dass man es
jetzt pro Jahr nicht schafft sagt man
einfach wir verschieben das sind die
Zukunft und dann haben wir
möglicherweise kein Problem weil
vielleicht regieren wir dann ja auch gar
nicht mehr ich glaube das ist nicht das
ist nicht der Punkt die wollen ja alle
gerne weiter regieren ich glaube dass
ist
deshalb so kompliziert weil es diese
billigen E-Autos ja gibt und was sie tun
in diesem in diesem verschieben oder
oder verhandeln von sektorzielen ist
halt noch ein
Schutzprogramm für die deutsche
Autoindustrie mitzuliefern und das kann
ich ehrlich gesagt nicht verstehen wenn
deutsche Autohersteller wenn deutsche
Autohersteller das verpennen am
preiswerter E-Autos überhaupt einen
preiswerte Flotte zu entwickeln und die
eben rechtzeitig auf den Markt zu
bringen und wir sehen ja ich meine wir
reden heute nicht gerne über China und
wir reden auch nicht gerne über über
asiatische Autohersteller aber da gibt
es preiswerte Modelle und was sie machen
ist jetzt zu sagen wir schieben das nach
hinten weil wir darauf warten das
Volkswagen so weit ist und das ist eben
keine Klimapolitik sondern das ist
Industriepolitik das ist ein bisschen
Klimapolitik vielleicht aber da wird so
viel zusammen verhandelt dass eben
dieses angeblich große Ziel bei uns ist
Klima die Nummer eins und die Nummer 2
und die Nummer 3 dass das eben nicht
mehr stimmt weil es gerade im Raum steht
bevor wir dann gleich was bauen wirklich
sprechen weil auch da die Details total
interessant sind und dann schließen wir
den Verkehr auch ab warum unterstützt
das die SPD diese FDP-Position und noch
mal um den Preis dass wir uns auf
Europaebene echt blamiert haben auch die
haben ein richtigen Hals wenn man mit
den wenn man da mal so reinhorcht weil
die sagen das kann nicht sein das
beschädigt auch dieses Projekt Europa
wenn hinterher jeder wieder ankommt und
sagt übrigens was wir da mal verabredet
haben vor ein paar Monaten war gar nicht
so gemeint machen wir jetzt nicht mehr
so kann man ja nicht arbeiten jetzt
müssen wir ein bisschen aufpassen dass
wir nicht mit Abziehbildchen von
Parteien arbeiten das was ich zumindest
gerade zum Thema e-Mobilität gesagt habe
ist spd-position pur würde hier in
liberaler sitzen hätten sie mit dem
wahrscheinlich jetzt schon fünf Minuten
über ifuels diskutiert alles Technologie
absolut nicht weil das ja alles
technologieoffen ist und die dem eine
ganz große Bedeutung zu müssen
nein wir sind vertragstreu das ist
überhaupt erstmal die Position wir haben
beschrieben und die Grünen ganz genauso
im Koalitionsvertrag dass wir uns im
Rahmen des europaweiten Einsatzes für
ein Verbrenner Verkaufsverbot ab 35 das
ist das was jetzt beschlossen wurde
gleichzeitig dafür einsetzen das
klimaneutrale
verbrennertreibstoffe also efuels wie
wir jetzt dazu sagen dass da ermöglicht
wird dass die zum Einsatz kommen wenn
ausgeschlossen ist das klassischer
konventioneller Diesel oder Benzin in
den Tank eingefüllt werden können so und
ob man das jetzt für zukunftsträchtig
hält oder nicht da haben SPD und Grüne
übrigens eine sehr ähnliche Einschätzung
zu dass das nicht sehr wahrscheinlich
ist naja wir hören der
Automobilindustrie beim Entwickeln auch
ein bisschen zu und finden nicht so
viele die so viel Begeisterung an dem
Thema finden wie die FDP aber geschenkt
es verhindert erstmal nicht dass wir aus
dem Verbrenner verkauft mit klassischen
Kraftstoffen
35 aussteigen so und das ist jetzt dort
beschlossen worden und natürlich stehen
wir als Bundesregierung als Koalition
gemeinsam ein für das was wir vereinbart
haben und wenn die Europäische
Kommission vertreten durch den
zuständigen Kommissar meint
vorne rum sagen zu können ja ja wir
machen das so wie mit euch verabredet
und hintenrum allen dies nicht hören
wollen erzählt dass man die deutsche
Bundesregierung und die FDP da jetzt mal
schön über den Tisch ziehen wird dann
können wir das so nicht durchgehen
lassen weil so kann man nicht
zusammenarbeiten weder zwischen
Kommission und deutscher Bundesregierung
noch innerhalb einer Bundesliga ich
verstehe ganz gut Herr Kühnert dass sie
sich das nicht gefallen lassen wollen
und das ist ja auch irgendwie fieses
fieses Verhalten nur dass man eben Dinge
zusagt und die da nicht macht und dann
denkt damit kommt man durch was ich
nicht verstehe ist wenn man mit seiner
Energie irgendwie haushaltet auch mit
seiner regierungsenergie dann würde man
doch sagen was verkämpfe ich mich für
den Mist also wenn Eve Treibstoffe im
Jahr 2035 noch so selten und so teuer
sind wie sie diskutieren und wie sie
annehmen wie die Grünen sagen wie sie
alle denken wahrscheinlich
genauso wie mit mit mit mit gaskesseln
wenn Erdgas so teuer zweitens und wenn
die co2-abgaben auf fossile Rohstoffe so
hoch sind wie wir das annehmen dass sie
gehen müssen dann frage ich mich warum
reden wir denn dann und warum streiten
sie denn dann tagelang wochenlang
monatelang über diese furchtbaren Themen
wenn die sowieso aus dem Markt
verschwinden weil das zu teuer ist aber
das ist
doch jetzt kein Klimaschutz im
Verkehrssektor dadurch verhindert worden
wenn unser Annahme stimmt
mit einem Streit um nichts
den Fehler gemacht aus meiner Sicht
erstens sind das Detailfragen die man im
Koalitionsvertrag hätte erklären könnte
aber auch oder dort konkreter hätte
ausformulieren müssen ein Jahr später
diskutieren wir über efuels die
vielleicht in der im Luftverkehr immer
sinnvoll sein können wunderbar also
lassen wir sie einfach machen die großen
Fragen Gebäude und Verkehr kommen jetzt
in einer Art Mini Koalitionsvertrag ein
Jahr später auf 16 Seiten teilweise
erstmals zur Diskussion wo ich mich
frage was habt ihr denn dann in der
Gesetzesarbeit in dem letzten 12 Monaten
gemacht wo ist das Klimaschutz
Sofortprogramm wo sind die neuen
Maßnahmen die Herr wissen dann eben
vortragen muss an stattdessen verkämpfen
wir uns seit Monaten über e-fuels und
über Wasserstoff oder Hybride Heizungen
die vielleicht kommen vielleicht auch
nicht aber eine Koalition die sich den
Fortschritt ja auf die Fahnen
geschriebene könnte doch einfach sagen
natürlich ist das bei uns erlaubt aber
hier sind unsere fünf Prioritäten wie
wir Klimaschutz einhalten wollen und die
ziehen wir jetzt mal dran machen
Schulterschluss machen müssen und nicht
mit der FDP zusammen
machen lassen Koalitionsvertrag vor 16
Monaten verabschiedet wenn wenn jeder
anfängt einem Koalitionspartner dem
etwas wichtig war anderthalb Jahre
später zu erklären dass man sich doch
jetzt nicht so haben soll wegen diesem
einen kleinen Punkt dann gibt es keine
Koalition mehr so kann man nicht
zusammenarbeiten
12 € Mindestlohn für 6 Millionen
Beschäftigte sollen wir jetzt so ein
Heckmeck machen so funktioniert das
nicht Verträge müssen eingehalten werden
und wenn an sich zu etwas nach langem
wochenlangen Verhandlung bekannt hat
dann muss ein Koalitionspartner sich
auch darauf verlassen können dass die
anderen mit einem mitkämpfen selbst wenn
sie nicht restlos übertutzt sind
ich meine warum wirklich schöne Frage
auch wenn es Blödsinn würden egal wie
sich die Preise fürs entwickeln entweder
ist es super dann sind die so preiswert
dass es egal ist wer damit rumfährt weil
sie dem Klima nicht mehr Schaden oder
sie sind zu teuer das kann er damit
rumfährt weil sie einfach zu teuer sind
dann ist also dann könnte man doch würde
man doch vernünftigerweise sagen wenn
man keine blödsinnig also wenn man keine
keine Politik nur machen will um sich
gegenseitig zu versichern wir sind super
Vertrags treu würde man doch
vernünftigerweise sagen wir lassen
einfach den CO2-Preis so hochlaufen das
ist ein dummes und taubes Instrument
aber wir lassen ihn hochlaufen und dann
werden sich die Leute schon vernünftig
verhalten